the chosen successor of ego Chavez may
have reached his goal but it was a
razor-thin victory for Nicolas Maduro
nonetheless he called on his rival and
rika Capriles to concede defeat kapri
layers I told you and I say it publicly
if I lose by one vote I'll hand over to
you tomorrow but that's not how it
happened I won by three hundred thousand
votes it's the decision of the people
but capri lasers supporters want to
recount the forty-year-old center-right
opposition leader says his team has a
list of more than 3,000 irregularities
nosotros we will not recognize the
results until each and every Venezuelan
vote one by one has been counted cada
rato de la venezolano uno por uno news
of the election outcome hit many caprino
supporters hard they'd hoped for a fresh
beginning and big changes to the
economic system the chair visitors are
aiming to stay the socialist course set
out by their iconic leader fueled by the
nation's oil wealth but even if maduros
win is confirmed this election has shown
just how deeply divided post chávez
venezuela still is